you will recall volumes we took apart
the idea of you don't need to write this
now and we took apart the idea of let's
do this way we took apart this idea are
just finding the volume of a solid of
revolution and we saw with techniques
right like it's it's kind of really
beautiful how compact and I'm succinct
this little thing is and how powerful it
is you know you can get some weird and
wonderful shapes out of this however
mathematicians always try to push the
boundaries and also trying to dig deeper
and deeper and deeper into what the true
nature of these kinds of things ah so
you might have remembered then what we
did was saying look this integral right
it actually kind of skipped a step it
kind of takes out it sort of disguises
it veils something that's happening
before where does this come from what is
integral come from i'll give you until
it starts with this limit as Delta X
approaches
hi okay so in this particular case in
this particular case I've just got that
we saw okay so this is a bunch of
infinitesimally thin cylinders okay we
we develop like a fundamental theorem of
calculus gets us to this mechanism where
integration gives us this result but
then we simple why just cylinders why
Drusilla's we introduce the idea of an
annular slice it's like look this slice
here can be a sort of it can be anything
you like right then we saw just that
subtle twist in the perspective on our
questions it opened up a whole bunch of
different kinds of things for us we
didn't anymore have to rotate around a
corner accents like the x axis or the y
axis I could take that line somewhere
else right and that is exactly what
we're going to do here last time we took
her kornaks and we just moved it we
shifted it right so that was cool but
this is gonna pale its go back to get a
pale in comparison to this here is a
what's that green shape called again
starts on the nest it's a segment
segment the sector would be not lap
hopping which in this case would be a
quadrant this is a segment so I want to
form a volume by rotating this segment
we can retake you certain a whole bunch
of different ways but I'm going to be a
little interesting and say what if I
take the cord that subtends this segment
and make that my axis of rotation ok now
this point to unit you is just like flip
the table into her ok because we don't
have anything really to deal with this
you have to do some pretty dramatic
twisting around you'd actually literally
have to rotate this in order that this
line which is a bleak i'm going to call
this an oblique axis of rotation in
order to make that horizontal or
vertical and then you could try
something like this okay but can we deal
with it the way it is well first I'll
let's get a picture of what this volume
is going to be like got this guy right
you spin the lane you're getting a shape
which will be symmetrical about this
line by the way what is the equation of
this court why because this is the unit
circle right this is one and one the
gradient of this line is negative one so
it's just one takeaway x okay so I'm
spinning around y equals one takeaway X
so I should be as I look at this at this
2d representation I should be I should
have wine symmetry around that life yeah
so let's reflect across and get
something like that okay it's a bit
feelin that big a deal and just for
effect right I'm gonna put some some
spinning line tears you're like okay
yeah it's a pointy football cool that's
what my volume is going to look like
where am I going to slice this now we
actually have some serious choices here
but so far everything we've been doing
in terms of like thinking back to what
we do that before and to you is to slice
in which direction what way am I going
to go here yeah 45 degrees to what up to
the 45 degrees which way and to me which
coordinate axis what future I Benedict
felicity so let's just pause for
checking right you guys know how excited
I am a language right here on technology
and this is why because we don't have
powerful language you just kind of like
you know the line with the thing and the
guy with the stuff and you have no way
to specifier right just do don't have no
shot UConn it a bit by race and where is
being a pain do you mean that way
because that's the very thing this way
it's written this way yeah but you cut
it along okay so let me hit again so
this is justify my language is awesome
right let me give you the way that I'll
describe it i am going to slice across
this volume on a plane perpendicular to
the axis of rotation that's all you need
to say perpendicular to the axis
rotation right if you want to go with
angles and that kind of thing I guess
you would say 45 degrees anti-clockwise
where extension to students so we know
anti-clockwise is actually the normal
direction of rotation not clockwise and
all the physics dudes there are 2 i'm
going to go 45 degrees or i should
really say pi 0 for anti clockwise from
the x-axis that would do it now let's
draw one of the slices draw one of the
slices this is a football right unlike
I'm willing an annular slices you're not
going to get any holes in this side
right so just draw money for me
ok there's my / sir being that actually
in this case you're just going to get a
cylinder just going to get us up you
only need to know two pieces of
information to work out what the volume
of the cylinder is right what are the
two pieces you're gonna need to know our
radius and I hi that's all you need now
let's have a look at the radius first
I'm going to draw this year over here
here's my radius I'm just gonna call it
little arcs I don't have a bigger okay
how am I going to work in that out where
does that come from yeah okay very good
I have this line over here right this is
straight line and this distance
everywhere along is the distance from
that straight line to some point on this
Ark yes so I'm gonna have to work that
out later on fine i'm just going to pile
that away over here then I think about
the height that's this guy okay now in
the past we've been saying ah Delta X if
you're going this way and Delta Y if you
go in this way but you are going neither
of those directions you're actually
going some combination of it okay so
there's lots of different ways I could I
take you like this but for me because
it's a higher right and it's neither X
nor why I'm just going to call it a time
thing i'm going to call it Delta H this
is a new variable I'm introducing and I
want you somehow have to convert from
this into the familiar old x and y's
because eventually i'm going to do some
integral right so eventually i'll get
there now the question then becomes ok
this is the substance of the question
how do i find out what r is how i find
out what Delta itches ok so let's start
with easy one let's do up ok and we
don't need a new diagram for our
everything we need is on here let's
define a point this is our particular o
our particular slice that we've chosen
so being that it's on the singham's i'm
gonna call this like a
and it's on the circumference like that
it just has some arbitrary coordinates I
will take advantage of the fact that
it's on the unit circle a little bit
later on but it's some arbitrary X Y
then how do I work out the distance
along here this distance here from AE to
dislike very good so i'm going to write
this as and again i needed some more
labels so i'm going to call this cord p
cute right this radius that I'm after
what it really is is the distance from P
Q that's the line to a that's not very
sophisticated our notation now I could
write other ways but i think its owner
because what I'm trying to get on okay
perpendicular distance in order to use
the perpendicular distance formula I
need this guy but I need it slightly
differently right how am I gonna rewrite
this ax plus B y plus C equals 0 there's
my general form so now I'm ready
actually put this into the perpendicular
distance formula what is the
perpendicular distance formula here it's
yeah it's a x1 plus B Y 1 plus C so
conveniently for me because the exit why
that I'm going to our exit why I just
have this on my numerator okay what
about my joy now cool so now
I have a radius I'm really cool it does
look at the icky at the women especially
with that square root on the bottom and
absolutely that but don't forget what am
I going to do with this radius when I
start to work out the volume answer I'm
going to square okay so I'm just going
to leave that there for now i'll come
back to it now let's deal with this
Delta H okay